[Applause]
what up internet I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it's March 15 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals if you want to chat with us
during the show add commentary spar with
other members it was a little spicy in
the chat yesterday I was told uh you can
join us at reubenreport.locals.com as
for that cold open this morning I don't
know exactly why we used that one but
it's like these people are all
ridiculous and well I guess I do know
why because we're going to show you some
slightly less ridiculous people today
and some very very uh even more so
ridiculous people but before we do any
of that and before we get to svb and
before we get to Biden trying to ban
guns and all the other craziness of the
world there is a story that you probably
have not seen
that has been breaking over the last
couple days that is so hilarious so
ridiculous such a perfect example of
everything that is wrong with everything
that we have to show you this clip it is
this is wild this is absolutely wild
everyone on earth needs to see this it's
so spectacular so Newark New Jersey you
guys know Newark New Jersey the mayor of
Newark New Jersey
did a sister city uh situation with
another nation and these things happen
you know you hear about this you know
London is a sister city of New York City
or something like that these things
happen sometimes they do it you know
Canada is a sister country with Zimbabwe
or whatever it might be
Newark New Jersey became a city sister a
sister city
with an imaginary place and there was a
whole freaking procession for it it is
just so incredible we're going to show
you some local news to kick off the show
apropos of nothing else other than what
in the world is happening on this planet
go
what started off as a seemingly
well-intentioned partnership has turned
into a giant embarrassment for the city
of Newark earlier this year mayor Ross
Baraka invited what he thought was the
Hindu nation of kailasa to Newark city
hall for a cultural trade agreement but
it turns out kailasa is no Nation at all
it's a fake very embarrassing for the
city I truly don't even have words for
it I'm really sorry for the city that
they got duped in that way though it has
a detailed website kailasa has no real
government it's the brainchild of Swami
nithyananda a notorious scam artist and
fugitive from India who has been on the
run from rape charges since 2019. a few
days after the papers were signed city
council rescinded the agreement this is
an oversight
could not happen any longer in a
statement City Hall said although this
was a regrettable incident the city of
Newark remains committed to partnering
with people from diverse cultures in
order to enrich each other with
connectivity support and mutual respect
but there first up the statement at the
end of course somehow it had to get
diversity into the statement we are so
into diversity we will make up Nations
to partner with it's just so perfect
like just everything about it like like
incompetence and fold
fake nonsense related to diversity it
just it's just so perfect there's
something nice about watching a local
news program you know like a little news
package from the local people you forget
what that used to be like but uh cayasa
I thought that's where the wookies were
from but apparently not that's something
else we've got to make cayasa great
again we're going to get the uh the
foreign minister of cayasa on the show
to clean this up I mean
anyway that's a bit of a throwaway today
uh the show really now let's get to the
real meat of the show
we should make chiasa t-shirts I'm not
kidding like insane just insane but the
real meat of the show today is that all
of this woke policy and the woke culture
and by the way there's a little meme
going around the internet right now
that people cannot Define woke that
everyone says woke but cannot Define it
I was actually on Newsmax yesterday they
asked me about it I defined it pretty
quickly I didn't even know they were
going to ask me the question but in
essence let me just do this once right
here on the show in case you're just
catching up and you have no idea what
woke means woke is basically the desire
for Equity equal results rather than
equality which is equal opportunity
right those are the the basics of it
through a racialized or sexualized lens
and then the subsequent destruction of
everything we knew to be true that is
pretty much it you can find out more I
did a little Twitter thread on it this
morning too destroying Ted Lou
congressman Ted Lou who's just an
absolute clown anyway uh the point of
the show today is that between woke
policy and and the culture wars that are
raging uh you've got to try to stay sane
throughout all of it so we've got some
funny clips for you later in the show
and you've got to just be able to to
understand what the issues are and then
go ahead and live your life that really
is the point these guys are going to
make it really difficult because they're
going to cause Financial meltdowns
they're going to cause political crises
worldwide pandemics and everything else
but there is a way to pilfer out a good
life through this right there really is
that's what my focus is here it's what
my focus is in my life it's what we're
all trying to do I think it's what
you're trying to do and that's what
we're going to get you to today uh
before I get to it let me talk to you
guys about Birch gold real quick you
know you can buy gold and get a free
safe to store it in with Birch gold
that's right on qualifying purchases
from Birch gold group now through March
31st they'll ship a free safe directly
to your door visit birchgold.com Dave to
get your free info kit on gold and claim
eligibility for your free safe here's
the deal the feds keep raising rates
because it's the only tool they have to
keep inflation under control just ask
the executives at svb and it ain't
working guys you can't spend your way
out of inflation you've seen the impact
act on the Stark stock market you've
seen the impact on your savings hedge
inflation by owning gold whether
physical gold and silver in your safe or
through an IRA and precious metals where
you can hold real gold and silver in a
tax sheltered retirement account Birch
gold has an A-Plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied customers visit birchgold.com
Dave today for your free info kit on
gold and to claim eligibility for your
free home safe by March 31st that's
birchgold.com David now back to me okay
let's dive right into it have you heard
of this Jordan Peterson fella I think
I've mentioned him once or twice on the
show Jordan is the leading I would say
public intellectual in the world I don't
think there is a human being on Earth in
modern times that has affected the
thinking in a positive fashion uh more
than Jordan Peterson Jordan went on
Tucker Carlson last night
he's on a mini break from the tour
starting up again in about six weeks I
think he went on Tucker Carlson last
night to discuss the dire consequences
that are occurring because of this
conflation between wokeness and climate
law uh it's quite good it's about a
minute long take a look
the modern environmental movement
doesn't seem to be doing a lot for the
actual environment it's my observation
what do you think that's about
well I think the best example of that's
probably both Sri Lanka and Germany I
mean Sri Lanka absolute Wasteland at the
moment as a direct consequence of idiot
hypothetically environmentalist policies
and then in Germany energy is much more
expensive than it was it's much more
unreliable than it was the Germans are
dangerously dependent on dictators and
the Russians
and that's all a consequence of
hypothetical environmentalist policies
so even by the standards laid down by
the environmentalists themselves
the policies that were put in place that
were pro-environmental are failing so
when you hear people say things like
human beings are nothing but a cancer on
the face of the planet or there's too
many people for the on the planet for
the earth to to feed let's say then
you're seeing reflections of that
underlying
pseudo-religious narrative and it's
extraordinarily dangerous
it's just the best the line that I
really like they're hypothetical
environmentalist policy that is what is
constantly being pushed on us the green
New Deal don't use your gas stove don't
drive or turn your lights on etc etc as
of course we know the very people
pushing this are flying their private
planes all over the world to tell you
what you should eat you should eat bugs
by the way they should eat filet mignon
I am having filet mignon tonight we're
having some friends over but
hypothetical environmentalist policy the
point being that they purport
it to do good for Mother Earth but it
often doesn't and then you end up in a
situation where we actually push decent
Western societies to make alliances with
countries say China Saudi Arabia Saudi
Arabia or Iran uh to fall in with them
because we aren't doing what we got to
do here now what do what do I mean by
that well what can we do here America
has plenty of energy but you may
remember this this is Joe Biden in 2020
during the debates this is during the
Democrat debate saying that we will not
drill on federal lands to be clear we
have plenty of oil in and around the
continental United States and Alaska
there's some energy up there but this
was his plan back in 2020.
I just want to give him a chance to
respond and then we can come back we're
staying on this issue number one no more
subsidies for fossil fuel industry no
more drilling on federal lands no more
drilling including offshore no ability
for the oil industry to continue to
drill period ends
so that's pretty interesting because I
don't know if you know this but that guy
ended up becoming president and he was
basically saying I'm going to destroy
the American Energy economy I don't care
how many people that puts out of work
what that does to our economy what that
does to your pocketbook what it does to
alliances around the world because other
countries were also dependent on energy
from the United States so he has waged
war on American energy from the Keystone
Pipeline to putting ESG in all of these
companies to the Ukraine war oh and uh I
guess I'll do a Joe Biden here
sure that we
blew it could have done
do it
hear this that's
the point guys here is that when you
demolish our non-renewable energy right
our fossil fuel energy the energy that
we have underground that has allowed
more people to become prosperous than
could have ever been imagined before say
a hundred years ago uh you will actually
destroy sectors of the U.S economy and
abroad while at the same time you're
going to push Nations as I just said
you're going to push good Nations to our
adversaries say Russia China and Saudi
Arabia they are going to form new
alliances against us it's what's
happening right this very moment check
this out this is from Reuters Saudi
Prince Mohammed bin Salman cemented a 10
billion dollar deal for refining and
petrochemical complex in China on Friday
meeting Chinese president XI jinpin who
urged joint efforts to counter extremism
and Terror Saudi Arabia signed 35
economic cooperation agreements with
China worth a total of 28 billion
dollars at a joint investment Forum
during the visit Saudi State News Agency
Spa said China is a good friend and
partner to Saudi Arabia president Xi
Jinping told the crowd Crown Prince in
front of reporters the special nature of
our bilateral relationship reflects the
efforts you have made at a g who has
made stepping up China's presence in the
Middle East a key foreign policy
objective despite its traditional
low-key role there trade between the two
countries increased by 32 percent last
year he said Saudi Arabia also said it
was working to add Chinese to the
curriculum in Saudi schools and
universities
do you guys get how absolutely massive
this is and how it is 100 percent
connected to the failure of this
Administration Biden says we will not uh
we will not allow for digging of oil and
we're not going to do any of this stuff
and we're not going to Frack we're going
to basically handicap our own energy
sector here and we're gonna do
everything we can to get off oil so then
Saudi Arabia which has a lot of oil it's
going well boy we're sitting on an awful
lot of oil U.S seems kind of nutty can
we find a new place to sell oil and then
China which is a big country as Kamala
Harris would say big country it's a big
place
it needs oil they're going through an
industrial revolution they are growing
and they are growing fast so we
basically push Saudi Arabia which is
Saudi Arabia is always teetering between
the west and the East right it's always
right there doing some good things doing
some bad things we now pushed them to
China and now we are back to square one
Biden is now forced because we ain't
going to take it from Saudi Arabia
anymore he's forced to drill on U.S land
even though he just said in those
debates that he wasn't going to do it
because we are having a short of and
it's a shortage and it's because he is
now pushing all of these countries to
Russia China uh and Iran and we have a
massive problem and they're kind of
lining up against us so yes you're not
going to believe it despite what Joe
Biden said in 2020 when he was trying to
become president here's what he's doing
right now
U.S President Joe Biden has approved a
controversial oil and gas drilling
project in Alaska despite widespread
opposition because of its likely
environmental and climate impacts
it's known as the willow oil project the
drilling area lies within the Arctic
Circle activists have dubbed it a carbon
bomb
supporters of the willow projects say it
will create local investment and
thousands of jobs
Biden has imposed limits on oil and gas
drilling in 16 million Acres of Alaska
and the compromise move
they have to understand what a farce
these people are Biden knew that he was
not going to stop all drilling right
maybe he was going to stop some of the
subsidies I don't even think we've
stopped all of that but all we have done
here is hamper our own nation and now
Biden is going ahead he's looking around
and despite the activists because
whoever is in charge of bite it's
obviously not Biden isn't a completely
insane person they're 99 insane but not
completely so they are looking around
going boy we do need some of our energy
we can't be completely dependent on
China and Saudi Arabia and Iran and all
of these countries this is not good so
yes we are going to go ahead and drill I
have no problem with us drilling I am
actually a hundred percent okay with us
Drilling and you should be okay with it
too we should be for energy Independents
when you are independent as a nation
whether it is financially independent
just think of your own life when you're
financially independent remember the day
you get off your parents Dole and you go
I got a job and I got a car and I got an
apartment and I'm free you you start
becoming a a fully actualized person
well America could have been a fully
actualized Nation we we've basically
been a fully actualized nation and we
are now regressing thanks to these
people they are saying no no no no we
should not drill we should not be energy
independent but obviously we should be
because when you're energy independent
and your economy is self-sufficient and
you can produce things like we used to
in the United States we don't anymore
then you don't need things from
everybody you don't have to enter
alliances
with countries that are doing a lot of
bad stuff you aren't basically held over
the barrel uh when push comes to shove
so he didn't accomplish his objective of
pausing drilling instead he's normalized
relations between America's enemies
countries that we thought we were
against are now kind of locking up
together uh it's not just Saudi Arabia
and China uh it's Saudi Arabia and Iran
and guess who uh brokered the deal China
video
so the big question you may be asking
what role did the United States play in
bringing two hostile nations with
terrible records on human rights
together the answer it didn't here's
Brian live former director of Iranian
Americans for Liberty there is no doubt
that the Optics of this new peace deal
between these two countries brokered by
China sends a message to the world that
the United States of America has lost
our position of leadership on a world
stage if China is negotiating peace
deals between Muslim countries this is
game over for America on a foreign stage
as we just have to accept that under
this Administration the world alliances
are really shifting people are not
looking at America as a leader America
is not looking at itself as a leader
sure we'll fund some Wars we'll give
money 100 billion 160 billion to Ukraine
that sort of thing to keep the money
money laundering going there but when it
comes down to it right now we are
pushing China Russia Iran Saudi Arabia
we're pushing them into a new alliance
and who is our alliance going to be
at the end of the day I don't know I
don't know because who would look at us
and be like boy America does seem like
it has good leadership and is on the
right track most Americans don't think
that so I don't know why someone from
another country would but this is
exactly what happens when you let woke
leaders prioritize woke policies on a
global scale and when I say that I am
not just using woke in some amorphous
term I'm telling you that ESG and the
hyper-racialization of everything and
focusing on diversity equity and
inclusion which have infected every
single one of our institutions which
have worked all the way up through into
the government all the way up through
all our education institutions into our
energy sector everywhere when you focus
on that you will destroy everything that
it touches so we will get energy
shortages while our adversaries will be
strengthened so let's let's connect this
to a little bit of what's going on here
domestically obviously the big story of
the last couple days is the failure of
Silicon Valley bank and then the
government came in even though
everyone's only in insured up to two
hundred fifty thousand dollars according
to the FDIC we've all seen that when we
go to the bank they got that little gold
sticker on the window when you're
handing in your check the government
came in and bailed them out so that
means that the government takes money
which it doesn't have prints more of it
devalues money and makes sure that these
Banks stay or that the people the bank
uh the people that work at the bank are
all going to be fired all the top up
people but in essence that all of the
people who have deposited money in them
will be secure now as I said the other
day I'm not here to uh to have anyone's
life destroyed and you want checks to be
paid and people to get what they're owed
uh but if the government keeps doing
this forever then there really is only
one bank and that's the United States
and that is a problem so get this even
on MSNBC The televised mental
institution of MSNBC even they are
admitting that there is a problem
related to wokeness as it uh connects to
the banks because svb Silicon Valley
Bank they didn't have a chief risk
officer for most of their existence they
hired one for just a little bit of time
but they had an entire department
devoted to diversity equity and
inclusion that might cause you to hire
the wrong people to do the jobs to make
sure you're making good Investments so
your bank doesn't fail and even on MSNBC
they understand that I mean this is
bananas
they got tons of new business they ended
up with almost 200 billion dollars and
what did they do with it they made a
horrible move they didn't even have a
credit risk officer a chief risk-off
officer for part of the time and they
invested in treasuries and
mortgage-backed securities just before
interest rates
have a chief risk officer for most of
the time I mean really think about that
you're a bank a chief risk officer comes
in and says hey people have given us a
hundred million dollars here are the
things we want to do with that money
because a bank wants to make money so we
want to invest in some safe things some
risky things and that way you know some
things might fail but some things might
succeed I mean this is what we all do in
our own life with Investments and
whatever it is that you do with your
money you don't just gamble every I'll
put everything on black you go to a
casino you might mix it up a little bit
you might go oh I can't do everything
with all of my money I got to keep a
little bit in my pocket they did not
have a chief risk officer for a certain
period of time this is a problem but
they did have a diversity equity and
inclusion Department to make sure that
they had a certain amount of black Trans
lesbians working there this is an issue
by the way I hope this story absolutely
blows up Gavin Newsom governor of
California Evil Lizard person and I mean
that literally I believe him to be a
lizard person wearing human skin he not
only his wineries which he has several
wineries or worth millions of dollars
they banked at Silicon Valley Bank but
it now turns out that he personally
banked there as well and he lobbied Joe
Biden to bail out the banks okay so that
story is just breaking over the last day
or so hopefully we'll get more on that
but if you want to see what Signature
Bank was focused on which connects up to
everything that we've talked about here
when you look at Joe Biden going we're
not going to drill he knows it's not the
right thing to do but he knows it's the
woke thing to do right because climate
is going to kill all of us well what was
Signature Bank doing what was Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank doing
they were not focused on making proper
Investments they were mostly focused on
pride and equity and inclusion Tucker
broke that down
here is Scott Shea the chairman of
Signature Bank welcoming his employees
to meeting of the bank's critical Pride
Council
this video is from last December just
months before Signature Bank slipped
beneath the waves and the pride Council
in question as you will see in a moment
featured a self-described genderqueer
trans-masculine person called Finn
Brigham who arrived to teach employees
about pronoun use watch I'm Scott Shea
chairman of Signature Bank and it is a
pleasure for me to welcome you to this
multi-media multicasted multi-spatial
meeting of the pride Council and I'm
just thrilled that there are about 40
people in the room I understand there
are something like 190 people that watch
parties so hi to you all at the watch
parties you know the most common
pronouns that folks are familiar with
are she and he becoming much more common
and you know I don't know if there's
anyone in the Signature Bank world but
probably you have clients that use they
them as pronouns they're gender neutral
pronouns on purpose we talked about
folks that are non-binary that
intentionally don't identify as male or
female so some of those folks who
Tuesday them as their pronouns Z is
another gender-neutral pronoun and the
other part of that would be here spelled
h-i-r
all right first off the guy had a Hitler
mustache did anyone notice that go back
later and watch it the guy that they
brought in to talk about diversity
Equity inclusion has a Hitler mustache I
thought Hitler was supposed to be a bad
guy to these people
what is going on here but do you see the
point guys instead of doing anything
that had to do with proper banking at
Signature Bank and at Silicon Valley
Bank all you do as a banker try to
picture a banker in 1950s New York
you're a banker and you get up in the
morning you put on your suit you have
your coffee at home you kiss your wife
and your kids you go to the bank and you
know what you do with the bank you do
Financial things people come in and
they'd like to open a checking account
and a savings account you sit down with
them and you give them a coffee maker or
a microwave old school and you say thank
you for your business I will do the best
I can with your money but what they do
now is bringing on trans Hitler to talk
about pronouns and then you wonder why
these places fail
foreign
so it's it's it's spreading everywhere
guys I mean this is the thing you could
look at Silicon Valley bank and go well
I don't care about Silicon Valley Bank
and I don't care about trans Hitler with
his pronouns or her pronouns whatever it
is I don't care about any of that it has
no connection to me the problem is in
the world that we live in now these
things are deeply connected so if One
Bank goes down people start freaking out
at other Banks they start taking their
money out next thing you know you find
out that your bank actually wasn't doing
everything on the up and up either this
is why ESG is so scary this is why Glenn
Beck wrote a whole book about it this is
why we've been talking about it here for
quite some time it's why Vivek Rama
Swami is running strive uh firm and why
he's running for president because these
companies EV all of the large
corporations basically in the United
States and all over the world right now
they've been infected by wokism where
they focus on things that have nothing
to do with the end product putting out a
good product getting a good result
making actual money allowing people to
flourish Etc et cetera so again if you
don't care about this uh you might have
to start hiding your cash under your
pillow because this is spreading to all
kinds of other Banks and by the way even
cash under the pillow or under the
mattress ain't gonna work because it's
going to as the banks fail you're the
cash under your pillow is also going to
be worth less we've got some info here
from CNBC shares of Credit Suisse on
Wednesday hit another all-time low for a
second consecutive day dropping by more
than 24 percent at one point during the
session trading in the bank's plummeting
shares trading in the bank's plummeting
shares was halted several times
throughout the morning the stock
recovered slightly around midday London
time but was still down over 20 percent
for the session
several Italian Banks were also subject
to automatic trading stoppages after
sharp declines on Wednesday including
unique credit finoco bank and Monte De
pashi hope I got that one right credit
suisse's largest investor Saudi National
Bank said it could not provide the Swiss
bank with any further financial
assistance according to a Reuters report
sparking the latest leg lower investors
are also continuing to assess the impact
of the bank's Tuesday announcement that
it had found material weaknesses in its
financial reporting processes for 2022
and 2021. in late 2022 the bank
disclosed that it was seeing
significantly higher withdrawals of cash
deposits non-renewal of maturing time
deposits and net asset outflows at
levels that substantially exceeded the
rates incurred in the third quarter of
2022. credit suisse's saw a customer
withdrawals of more than 100 10 billion
Swiss Francs in the fourth quarter as a
string of scandals Legacy risk and
compliance failures continued to plague
it okay so without getting into all of
the minutia of all of that and I get it
everyone only has a certain bandwidth
for any of this the point is that the
system across the board which is deeply
interconnected when One Bank fails other
Banks start failing but the problem is
if you don't let the banks fail and the
government comes in and it prints money
then the money is worth less and we get
more inflation we are in a very screwy
precarious spot you could probably well
not probably you can undoubtedly connect
all of this to 2018
2008 when we bailed out all of these
Banks we made banks that were quote
unquote too big to fail that was the
whole idea if these banks are too big to
fail meaning there's so many Assets in
them that if they fail it'll wreck the
world economy so what did we do we made
them even bigger right and now we're
just doing the same thing again and by
the way I can't sit here and tell you
that we absolutely should not do
anything because if we absolutely do not
do anything we rip that Band-Aid off we
might have riots in the streets all over
the world like all hell could break
loose maybe that's really what has to
happen in a way to get to a true reset
not a great reset but a true reset of
reality but like I don't want that right
like just imagine if all the banks fall
like what what would actually be
happening the murder in Mayhem and
everything else so the point is all of
this stuff is connected and
unfortunately we are governed by a very
unserious set of people uh even Moody's
now has downgraded their Outlook of the
entire U.S banking system we got a
little more on that
how should we be interpreting Moody's
decision now to downgrade the entire
banking sector well it's certainly a
sign of continued concern about these
Banks Moody's says that they expect that
banks are going to continue to remain
under pressure for as long as the
Federal Reserve hikes interest rates
they're warning they could downgrade six
U.S banks including First Republic Bank
Western Alliance and Comerica so why you
should again why should you care about
that well inflation is going up that
means your dollar is less so every week
that you get a paycheck the value of the
dollar that is in your paycheck you will
be able to buy less stuff and as we know
the the price increase of stuff just go
to Target go to Best Buy go to Amazon
stuff is starting to cost more and at
the same time the dollar is worth less
this is a problem when it goes like this
you'd like it to go something like this
that would be nice but that's not where
we're at right now so as the banks now
get downgraded what happens is the banks
all are looking around and they're going
man we could collapse at any moment
people start taking their money out they
start freaking out a little bit then the
banks don't want to lend as much because
they do it's risky lending in many cases
that got everyone into this right 2008
it was a housing lending we were
literally lending people that made fifty
thousand dollars a year we were lending
the million dollar mortgages not we the
banks were lending the million dollar
mortgages with you know five percent
down so you could put you know 20 grand
down or something ridiculous on a
million dollar house you'd have no way
of paying for it they did thousands and
thousands of these and then suddenly
everything collapsed at once but you
know a few people made their money on
the way out
so that is what the problem here is uh
Carl icann who is an American Finance
here he's also the founding and
controlling shareholder of icann
Enterprises I'm sure you've heard the
name before it's a public company uh and
uh it's a diversified conglomerate
holding company I wanted to get that
just right uh he has a very Stark
warning for everybody right now I told
you at the beginning of the show we were
going to get to some funny stuff today
and I promise you we will but this is a
very very dark and Stark warning about
what is happening to the banking system
right now
that system is breaking down and that we
absolutely have a major problem in our
economy today that the system is
breaking it out and one of the major
reasons not the only reason obviously
but what are the major reasons is
that you don't have good corporate
leadership so you say so what
but I'll tell you so what if you don't
have good corporate leadership companies
yeah when The Tide is High and things
are great it doesn't matter and all
these guys are running these companies
are partying and having a good time and
giving themselves bonuses
seeing what he said there you don't have
good corporate leadership so look it's
it's a conflation or it's a connection
between two things right so on one hand
you we have bad political leadership
there is simply no doubt about that
right I'm pretty sure if you're watching
this show you agree with me on that but
we don't have good corporate leadership
again what were the people at svb and at
Signature Bank and likely at Chase and
the rest of the banks doing through ESG
as opposed to figuring out what are the
best financial services for our clients
and our investors and our bank as an
entity
let's focus on how many trans people we
hire let's hot let's literally let's
give people promotions based on their
skin color and their genitals as opposed
to who are the most effective who are
the smartest and best investors the
people who know how to carry the one the
people who know how to do basic math and
can actually make a profit on all of
this so it is two things at once a huge
amount of it is the incompetence and and
dereliction of Duty of this
Administration but but also it is what's
happening in our corporate culture
because of wokism and where has this all
led to us well it's leading us an awful
lot closer to socialism right socialism
in essence would be as the government
and private corporations pretty much
work together against the man right
against the individual against you and
how does it always happen in socialist
societies you nationalize everything
right so you don't have private Banks
anymore you have banks that are run by
the government and that basically is
what we have right because the banks
were supposed to fail if they weren't
doing a good job right they were going
to fail if they weren't doing a good job
but you would have been backed by that
250 Grand FDIC insurance but instead we
just come in and save everybody
and again I get why they do it at some
extent I don't want all hell to break
loose but as we do this we we
nationalize everything and that is not
good to say the least here's former
deputy treasury secretary Roger Altman
uh telling us flat out what we are doing
right now
what the right what the authorities did
over the weekend was absolutely profound
they guaranteed the deposits all of them
at Silicon Valley Bank and what that
really means
and they won't say this and I'll come
back to that
what that really means is that they have
guaranteed the entire deposit base of
the U.S financial system the entire
deposit base this is a breathtaking step
uh which effectively nationalizes or
federalizes the deposit base
of the U.S financial system
I would argue this is exactly what the
walksters want I can't really connect
that directly to Joe Biden because he's
muddled and he's not in charge but this
is what they would want right they like
power and control so what happened over
the weekend A Bank through incompetence
and then also all the nonsensical things
related to the government in terms of
inflation and everything else a bank
failed and instead of letting it fail
letting nature take its course and
saying sorry to the people that put your
money here we knew you know Silicon
Valley Bank was known to do risky
Investments if you're Silicon Valley
it's baked into the name of the thing
right these are these are speculative
companies these are often as I described
over the last couple days like as a guy
that started a tech company locals you
run at a deficit for a while as you're
getting investment but you're not
bringing in a ton of money the hope is
you will get enough users to see that
your product is valuable and then
eventually you'll figure out how to
monetize that but they were just pouring
money into these things and now we have
in essence as Altman is saying we have
nationalized these Banks and at this
point why wouldn't we nationalize them
all and you might go well why is that a
problem it's pretty good nobody lost
their money here well that sounds kind
of right but in woke World things that
sound right are usually very wrong
because once you have One Bank in
essence you will have one Bank the
United States government all the banks
there'll be no difference between any of
the banks there'll be no competition
there'll be no way that you can leverage
one against the other to get a better
rate and then we will all be in a very
calcified uh
system where there is no ability to get
a better deal uh Mike cernovich you
remember Mike zernovich I've had him on
the show a couple times used to get a
lot of crap for having Mike cernovich on
but I think he's become one of our
better cultural and political thinkers
he had a tweet that I thought sum this
up quite well he said you all think
cancel culture is bad now wait until all
banking is Consolidated into two or
three New York Banks because smaller
Regional Banks and credit unions are
allowed to fail have you thought this
through at all or still stuck in 2008
talking points so what he's saying there
is you can see how the system is
centralizing right now if the system
comes in and will save certain Banks
well what it could do is say to other
Banks we are going to save you because
we like centralized power so then the
regional Banks through often through not
fault of their own just through bad
economic conditions that the government
is creating the regional banks will go
away now let's say we have two or three
Banks and they're deeply deeply
connected to the government
well now what happens if uh you're
somebody who's you know I don't know say
doing a political talk show and you're
saying things that they don't like could
your bank just call you up one day and
say uh hey we're cutting you off that
would be a problem wouldn't it I would
find that to be problematic as the kids
say so that's an issue right there
um you want flexibility so we have a
major problem right now the government
is going to pick the winners and the
losers and maybe they've been doing it
all along maybe they've been doing it
all along but it it seems like it is
strengthening right now so now let's get
because again I said we were going to
show you some more ridiculous stuff and
silly stuff and funny stuff uh how am I
connecting all of these things
the culture piece of this guys we have
unfortunately our our mainstream culture
has become deeply unserious it has it
has infected everything to the point
that our political Elite are woke and
don't care about the right things our
cultural Elite are woke and don't care
about the right things and then over
time it degrades everything our doctors
will not be as effective as they once
were our Pilots will not pilot as well
all of the stuff the bankers okay you
got it so what's going on culturally in
America right now well this one is a
doozy Drew Barrymore now I didn't even
know Drew Barrymore had a talk show did
you guys know about this before this
clip did anyone know about this Drew
Barrymore I mostly know her from She's
the love interest and several Adam
Sandler movies what was the one where
she can't remember anything
what was that hundred days of summer or
Camp what was it uh Adams what was it
50 First Dates thank you very much we're
fact-checking real time right here you
know what I mean uh but she's usually
she's in a lot of Adam's in other movies
and she's done some other things over
the years and she was in E.T okay she's
just fine anyway I guess she's got a
talk show right now and of course if you
get a talk show in Hollywood that means
you're awoke leftist crazy person so she
had Dylan Mulvaney on now you guys may
remember Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney
is a guy uh who then started dressing up
like a woman and doing all these videos
pretending to be a woman and saying that
he was a woman and apparently last we
checked but I'm not going to make you
Google it today because you've been
doing fine work and I don't want to
wreck your Google searches last we heard
Dylan still had a penis but she's she or
he has had a bunch of surgeries looks
like a chick on the outside I think
still has a penis you may remember that
he actually as a woman interviewed Joe
Biden at the White House and Joe Biden
said it's a moral responsibility for
allow for allowing genital mutilation I
mean these people are all insane anyway
Dylan Mulvaney so this is a woman Who We
Believe has a penis but you'll have to
do research on your own went on Drew
Barrymore's show as a woman and well
this is the craziest leading I've ever
said about anything just watch the thing
there is so much hatred directed to the
trans Community right now it's
everywhere and I think the greatest
weapon that I can contribute is trans
joy in comedy I look at someone like you
and I can't imagine anybody disliking
you oh please do you know do you want to
know ironically who uh dislikes me the
most sometimes myself oh me too oh
and but
I guess you're gonna do that for me now
like
you've asked me like what I would do to
combat the hate right yeah but what do
you do
guys how relief band did not sponsor our
show today because I almost barfed
during that thank God I have six relief
bands wrapped to my uh lower right leg
right now it's just ridiculous theater
it's all insane but speaking of theater
did you know that the Oscars were a
couple days ago I didn't watch them I
know I'm a racist what do I need to
watch the Oscars for to be lectured
about like I'm a racist white
supremacist homophobe I accept it and
then I move on with my day
Jamie Lee Curtis well give me a couple
Jamie Lee Curtis movies she was in
Halloween she was in that show with uh
what was that show with Richard Lewis
and her that was on for a couple years
not mad about you mad about shoe no what
the hell is that show anything but love
I think it was called anything but love
Richard Lewis Jamie Lee Curtis
anything but love
Richard Lewis Jamie Lee Curtis come on
Google listen anything about love I got
it was pretty decent show actually
anyway she's done a couple things over
the years what was the deal with her she
was born intersex she had like testicles
and a vagina or something anyway great
gal she also has that she she's big on
Activia which is the uh the yogurt when
you have stomach problems
whatever uh here she is apparently she
won an Oscar and she's naming her Oscar
or she's using the Oscar's preferred
pronouns of they them because of her
trans son or daughter take a look
I'm I'm in support of my daughter Ruby
I'm I'm having them be a they them oh
um I'm I'm gonna just call them them
they them and um they are doing great
Hollywood actress hugging and stroking
her ridiculous award to because that she
got because she pretends to do something
uh in honor of her trans child is just
like the perfect it's just perfect it's
just perfect I think we have a picture
of her they themed daughter or son
I will leave that without commentary
because my mom's probably watching and
she wants me to be nicer so we'll let
that be uh but it never ends it never
ends with these people the problem with
the woke class is you're never good
enough for them uh did you guys know
that uh Colin Kaepernick you know Colin
Kaepernick he was the football
quarterback NFL didn't want to stand for
the anthem kind of became washed up and
then teams didn't want teams didn't want
to have him not necessarily because he
was totally washed up but no one wants
to deal with the headache of of having
that in the locker room all the time but
he could stand or he could sit and fans
could stand or sit or salute the flag or
not everyone no one's Free Speech was
infringed on this is it's really
interesting did you know that he was
actually he's black okay nobody cares
except for him and the wokesters but did
you know that he was actually adopted by
white parents that's sort of an
interesting piece of the puzzle seeing
as he seems to hate white people and
whatever he defines as white culture and
all that uh well now he's turning on his
parents because his white parents who
adopted him a black boy Were Somehow
perpetuating racism against him
lordy lordy play the video
who's spreading
him change the game written with author
and universe
hago professor
yui it's his true High School
coming-of-age Story his journey
embracing his Blackness despite
resistance from many including his white
adoptive parents I know my parents love
me but they were still very problematic
things that
I went through teenage Kaepernick wanted
cornrows to match he's getting what
roles his mom asked oh your hair is not
professional oh you look like a little
Thug
said that to you yeah
a god someone's mother encouraged them
to dress a certain way or have a certain
haircut that is so racist
that's what parenting is like you want
your kid to go out there and look as
good and professional and as adult and
functional as possible to maybe get a
job or do better in schools but no they
adopted a young black boy that doesn't
prove their non-racism they are still
racist look guys all of this woke
culture flooding into our culture and
our entertainment it indoctrinates
people into voting in woke leaders which
leads to the fiscal incompetency the
foreign policy incompetency and the
dangerous outcomes that we are at right
now and then what's the other piece of
this the LIE laundering piece of this
the mainstream Media or should I say as
my friend Michael Malla says the
corporate press
they run cover for the incompetent
buffoons they run cover for the liars
and all of the people who get us into
this mess this you're going to need your
relief band again Jen saki okay she's
back baby so remember Jen saki who for
two years as a year and a half whatever
it was as Joe Biden's press secretary
she lied more than anyone now cringe
Jean-Pierre yes I said cringe not uh
Corinne cringe Jean-Pierre who's taken
over she's even worse than her which is
incredible and they should study this
like it's it's just remarkable but saki
for a year lies lies during covet about
everything right and what happens what
do you get well you have Democrat
privilege so then you get a gig for a
couple hundred grand a year on MSNBC to
continue lying I mean at least she was
qualified in this case like you're a
chief liar over here we're going to pay
you to lie at MSNBC but then you get to
go on all of the talk shows and you get
to tell everyone how good you are and
how bad everyone else is so here's Jen
sake on Stephen Colbert do I have to do
anything else about him this week
talking about the high standard of
Journalism and the Deep Integrity that
they have at MSNBC
so if your boss is an MSNBC which is
sort of sometimes called like a liberal
Fox I don't think it's entirely fair if
you were asked to do any of that stuff
what would you say
I would say no but I would never be
asked that asking it's a hypothetical
well I don't do hypotheticals way but
but B look I think this is an important
piece to dive into because MSNBC has a
very high standard of what is factual
you have to go through a process before
you report things on air to
it's so incredible like that we have to
do it again right they lied about the
hunter buying laptop they lied about
very fine people on both sides they lied
about Jesse Smith they lied about
January 6th they lied about Kyle
Rittenhouse they lied about the
Covington kids kovid like these people
lie about
absolutely everything okay everything
and in the book Rules for Radicals which
is what where most of this stuff comes
from that's part of it that is part of
it accuse others of doing exactly what
you are doing right that is that is
precisely what these people are doing
okay so what does gen saki cover over at
MSNBC what does she say on MSNBC is she
doing hardcore journalism or is she
running cover for the president and for
the administration and for the
government which used to be known as
what a hack would do but now it's known
as a journalist well here she is just a
day or two on MSNBC tell me if this
strikes you as honest journalism or is
this doing PR for an Administration
now it's
empathy at 9am he is a night owl so the
fact that he is doing this at 9am anyway
speaks to how vital the White House
recognizes it is for him to have his
voice out there conveying that to the
American public
all right Steve Ratner
that she was hired by a news
organization shows you the fraud right
there now I will agree with her that Joe
Biden probably does nothing at 9am I
actually believe that might be true but
if you think for one second that Joe
Biden is a night owl and does work at
night he's never seen at night isn't
that interesting they can usually put
him out they put him out from somewhere
between I don't know about 10 a.m to
maybe noon that's when you get Prime
Biden right and that's basically it and
I don't know if that has to do with the
drugs that they have him on or whatever
but you know there is something when
elderly people have the beginnings of
dementia Alzheimer's Etc there's
something about that hour I think they
call it the Sundown hour or something
like that that literally as the sun goes
down that's generally when they get more
confused there there's probably some
physiological reason for that if you
think for one second that Joe Biden is
burning the midnight oil and he's up
late you know picture he's in the white
house with the light on in the Oval
Office and everyone else is sleeping but
Joe Biden is working and I'm gonna
please please Corn Pop doesn't work that
late either so has she called out this
fiction yet or not because this was just
yesterday and this is Joe Biden 100
lying so I would hope saki I'm giving
you a chance I assume you'll be on MSNBC
later today here is a 100
Lie by Joe Biden yesterday you're going
to be on MSNBC today I assume so I'm
handing you one sake I'm handing you one
so that you can tell us the truth about
this thing because you guys have
journalistic integrity we're just a
bunch of crazy right wing disinformation
experts over here enjoy
that we invest more in safer communities
and expand access to Mental Health
Services for those affected by gun
violence
Congressional Republicans
should pass my budget instead of calling
for cuts in these services or defunding
the police or abolishing the FBI as we
hear from our Republican friends
uh did you catch that guys because you
know he slurred a couple words there but
did you catch that Congressional
Republicans are calling for defunding
the police
uh uh
we have a massive compilation of
Democrats uh calling for defunding the
police you've seen it many times I
didn't even want to play it just now
because you know it I don't have to show
you everything again you guys are too
smart my audience is actually too smart
so I don't have to show you things over
and over and over again every now and
again we repeat something to really
smack you with it ilhan Omar AOC blah
blah blah you got it they're the ones
that we're calling for it so he just
lied so Jen Saki
it's hockey
Joe Biden just lied you told Stephen
Colbert another Bastion of truth that
you guys have high journalistic
integrity and you don't lie let's not
forget John heilman who got demolished
by Russell Brand on Real Time with Bill
Maher a week or so ago for saying that
MSNBC people don't knowingly lie well
okay Joe Biden 100
lied right there and said Congressional
Republicans want to defund the police
and because of that that's why they have
to sign his budget that is a lie lady so
Jen saki my challenge to you and I
believe we're posting this video today
on the Internet it's we're on the
internet right now that's what they're
telling me that means people are going
to see this thing this thing has been
disseminated throughout the Universe
you must gen saki for the for the sake
of Journalism for the sake of Integrity
for the sake of MSNBC you must tell
people the truth but of course you will
not you will not we know you will not
and that is what leads us to the very
scary and dangerous times that we are in
woke leadership leads to bad outcomes
and now we have both
so besides political resistance which
I'm always talking about here how do we
fight it right how do we actually fight
it well you have to incorporate some
good ideas in your own life that will
help right you have to stop being so
reliant on other people and be more
reliant on yourself that's why they want
everyone handicapped and fat and stupid
and dumb and not knowing what truth is
and everything else because they want
you reliant on them I want you relying
on yourself frankly I don't care what
you're doing just stay out of my yard
that would be nice I really I became the
guy I became the guy stay off my lawn
that's where I'm at in life right now
that really is where I'm at so you know
what you have to do you have to beat
them with laughs you have to watch clips
of them and mock the hell out of them I
think we do a pretty decent job of it
here because that is the only way you
will stay sane because otherwise and
this is why so many lefties are bananas
they watch The View they watch MSNBC
they think they're watching something
true it has nothing to do with truth and
I believe that truth is so fundamental
to The Human Experience that if you are
constantly slammed with something untrue
you it will cause you to have some sort
of mental breakdown and speaking of
mental breakdowns here's a clip from The
View Anna Navarro and Anna as I always
say I know you lived somewhat close to
me and I look forward to seeing you
hopefully I'm going to see you one day
we're going to see Anna Navarro it's
going to be a great day I'm going to
turn to you I'm going to say Phoenix you
have to film this I'm about to approach
Anna Navarro and then she will you know
throw hot coffee in my face or something
it'll go viral be very exciting uh here
she is yelling I mean she's angry now
these people are very angry because I
think they're losing the narrative a bit
and here she is that Democrats must fall
in line we must fall in line behind dear
leader Joe Biden then wizard Kamala
Harris go
I don't know what the hell is wrong with
Democrats listen here's the bottom line
guys
Joe Biden is going to be your nominee
stop talking about how old he is and
Kamala Harris is going to be your vice
president so stop fretting stop ringing
your hands and get behind your ticket
because on the other side your
alternative is Donald Trump or Ron
DeSantis so you tell me what you prefer
board I don't speak to you often during
the show but please please let the next
president of the United States be Donald
Trump or Ron DeSantis please okay
because it will send that woman to a
mental institution I don't even know if
it's going to fix all the problems but
it will these people are bananas but you
see what I when I say you scratch a
progressive and you find an
authoritarian what does she want stop
thinking for yourself you will fall in
line behind Joe Biden cognitively genius
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris that's what
you'll do awful you know what's funny
like here I'm actually interviewing
Nikki Haley this afternoon we're gonna
go do that live at the local studio in
Miami I'm gonna try to interview all the
Republicans and I'll interview any
Democrats too you know we're going to DC
uh in a week and a half and I'm doing a
slew of interviews like 10 interviews in
a day and we've got all Republicans so
far we've reached out to elohan Omar
we've reached out to AOC we've reached
out to like the usual collection of
people and I would gladly interview them
Ted Lou you freak I crushed him today on
Twitter that's how I wake up now get off
my lawn and I'm gonna crush somebody on
Twitter
um Parenthood really does change you in
a way it really does it I think what
Parenthood has done to me sidebar first
just a second it is so solidified the
idea that I must fight for a better
world I was doing it already but now
like I see it man and I am not going to
let these people will win I just simply
am not going to do it
where the hell were we what was the
point of all that
all right let's move on to the next clip
so Anna and okay okay let's just get to
the Tucker clip here so what what is the
risk of all of this what is the risk
when they want people to fall in line
and not question the machine and accept
that we should having competent people
governing us what what is the Fallout of
all that well we're seeing the Fallout
right now right
but what you must do is you must take a
little joy in some of it uh Tucker
Carlson we played a couple Tucker Clips
on the show today so thank you Tucker
um you know this guy Jim Cramer Jim
Cramer is over on uh he's on CNBC and
this guy is incredible every prediction
that this guy makes he's a market guy
right he's I think he had a show Mad
Money I'm not sure even if they have
that show anymore but he goes on these
shows and he tells people what to invest
in but he always you know I'm telling
you what to invest in but don't follow
me he gets everything wrong like there's
there's a Twitter account that just
follows all of the things that he gets
wrong well just weeks ago not too long
ago maybe it was two months ago
something like that uh he was going on
and on about how great Silicon Valley
Bank is
Tucker had some fun with that
here is professional BS artist slash
dumb person Jim Cramer of CNBC telling
his viewers to buy Silicon Valley Bank
even if it was in the process of going
under this is last month
cancel don't you want
the base of Wall Street had mistakenly
concerned about
Silicon Valley Bank recently bought one
of our favorite research firms Buffett
Nathanson it's become less dependent
upon private equity and venture
capitalist offerings wait a second let's
try to play sure they could come back
long-term private Equity venture capital
and I'm going away being the banker to
these best immense pools of capital has
always been a very good business spb's
nearly 40 rally this year is barely a
drop in the bucket
this VP is great if that guy ever
endorses anything you're doing
move to the Canary Islands change your
name because disaster is coming
that's why you have to have fun with
this but also why it's hard to listen to
Jim Cramer like could you understand he
was like
and then people listen to it
Tucker's having fun with this whole
thing look at Tucker's new Twitter
profile this is a good one Tucker
Carlson non-binary climate change
activist of color Visionary Tech founder
CNBC Market analyst informal zielinski
advisor with two trans Flags pretty good
Tucker uh that's what you got to do guys
that's what you got to do and then to
end the show today this is just perfect
this is just perfect so Fox Nation aired
a documentary where the Nigerian
brothers who were hired by Jesse
Smollett remember the entire thing was a
hoax it was pushed on us by MSNBC and by
CNN Kamala Harris told us this proves
systemic racism Nancy Pelosi AOC they
all lied about everything but but that's
what they do they're all professional
Liars they fall for everything that fits
their narrative it's so weird every
every story that fits their narrative is
exactly perfect and when things don't
fit their narrative it's always from a
white supremacist or a misinformation
specialist it's wild
anyway Fox Nation did a documentary with
the Nigerian brothers who smilette hired
for the hoax okay and and they did this
in a funny like this is funny I don't
even know how this came to pass but here
are they're the asundario brothers here
they are walking through the events of
the hoaxed attack on Jesse Smith this is
just great
they took our beautiful bench this is
where we waited for Jesse to come before
we attacked them
so we got here with 10 minutes to spare
and we had to plan our Escape Route to
survey the land his building is actually
right here right above the stairs that
we're going to attack a man okay that's
him let's go
I gotta go get this Empire
[Music]
I mean he said what did you say to me
and then that's when I threw the first
punch at him
I held the blower because I didn't want
to hurt him of course so I made it look
real but I held it then we started
tussling moving moving around and then I
threw him to the ground I came around
with the Bleach the infamous bleach in
the hot sauce bottle poured it on his
shirt then I finally put the Rope around
his face I did not put it around his
neck I just placed it on his face and
that's when we took off
we're in The Matrix we really are in The
Matrix it's all made up it's all
nonsense and I seriously hope you
laughed or smiled at that like what is
going on here now those guys look
they're not guilty of uh of nothing
they're guilty of something right they
took the cash for the hoax and they
would have gladly got away with it but
then the whole thing fell apart
fortunately uh but it's like they're not
the true bad guys in this thing it's
Jesse smilette and it's every Democrat
and wilkester who fell in for the hoax
and tried to use it as a political
cudgel over the rest of us right like
this proves systemic racism and all the
rest of it like oh we're gonna get that
Empire
guys if you haven't subscribed join us
at rebel.com Reuben report we got a post
game show coming up at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with Russell Brand is up right
now as I said this afternoon we're
heading over to the local Studio to
interview uh Nikki Haley and then we are
going to try to interview everyone who
runs for president and I'm going to
treat them all the same I have my own
views I don't hide them but I'll treat
them all with respect
I'll try to get a little something more
out of each one of them and let the best
one win as opposed to Anna Navarro who
you must vote for Joe Biden Kamala
Harris is the greatest person on Earth
bow before me I'm a host on The View
here's Dave Chappelle on Jesse smilette
to finish us up and I'll see everybody
in the locals chat uh post game show in
just a sec okay
talking about all the time on the news
and and for some reason
uh African-Americans we will like
ah quiet about this the gay community
started accusing African-American
community of being homophobic for not
supporting him what they didn't
understand is that we were supporting
him with our silence
because we understood that this was
clearly lying
details added up at all
he said he's walking down the street in
Chicago and uh white dudes come up to
him and say hey man aren't you that
from Empire
[Applause]
does that sound like how white people
talk but never say that it sounds like
something
that I would say
you were racist and homophobic you're
not even know what this thing is you
can't watch Empire
[Applause]
Bible never feel sorry for the police
but this time we even felt sorry for the
police can you imagine if he was a
police veteran taking this kid's police
report okay Mr schmelier please tell me
what happened
all right
2 A.M we left the house at 2 A.M it's
minus 16 degrees
[Applause]
you were walking you're walking all
right
[Applause]
and and where were you going
Subway
sandwiches
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign